hey what's going on is Bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday [ __ ] Monday morning
podcasts that I'm just checking in on
you
how's that is that the worst is that the
worst you've ever heard they kept no
reference ah sorry my voice is a little
[ __ ] blown out did a record for
Episode six of the ten that we're doing
for season two and I don't know what the
[ __ ] I did to it
who's going to know when you know when
you lack Talent what you try to do is
you try to be loud so you can shout down
all the silence that's what you do you
throw in a couple of F words a couple of
[ __ ] [ __ ] jokes the next thing you
know you kind of have an act you know
and you scrape the bottom of the [ __ ]
barrel that's what you do and when you
scrape the bottom of the barrel next
thing you know you have your party's
nomination for presidency of the United
States you know it's great about this
job is I get to meet a bunch of
different people and overwhelmingly
people on both sides are just going I
don't know who the [ __ ] I'm going to
vote for these are my these are the
these are the two which is supposed to
decide out of the [ __ ] blue between
these two [ __ ] lunatics I don't get
it
well I get it what are you going to do
so either vote more the same or you step
off into the abyss I swear to God if
Trump didn't hate non-whites as much as
he seems to or Lisa wasn't so [ __ ]
out of touch I'd almost be excited just
to see what what just just being a lazy
comedian just how this guy would just be
[ __ ] feeding it to you you don't I
mean I found Obama was kind of boring
you know Bush was fun Clinton was Jesus
Christ Clinton was [ __ ] great you
know launch come over here and suck my
dick I mean it was so easy to get laughs
on that guy and then Bush I just got old
after a while we get it he's [ __ ]
stupid but like Clinton every
[ __ ] week he was sticking cigars in
people's [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know he's bombing people he's
putting on weight he goes to McDonald's
and he's got his [ __ ] thighs out I
mean that guy he was he was a he was a
comedy juggernaut because he kept
changing every time you thought you know
all right it's this this and this and
you got this guy down he would add
another layer Bush was just kind of
honky and then another [ __ ] seven
years I think it's like we get it we get
it he's [ __ ] stupid he's not stupid
but he saw I'll quote one of my
relatives he's not the best speaker I
barely even watched a bomb a bomb azores
a coal oh I was just felt like he was
giving me a [ __ ] lecture it's like
all right I never really found any Hume
I found his wife hilarious [ __ ] going
on Ellen and [ __ ] and tweeting you don't
I mean acting like some seventh grader
on Instagram she was funny but uh know
about him anyway so hopefully whatever
one of the other you can tell you right
now both of the either one of them
Hillary at Trump is going to be plenty
of [ __ ] material but then it'll
instantly be hacky so maybe that's what
it is I don't know all I know is I got
um I got I'm doing this Wednesday night
the hockey is over you get so excited to
see somebody win the [ __ ] Cup and
then there's like the next day like I'll
[ __ ] it's over now what do I do
I'll tell you what you do you get into
Formula One there's another race this
Sunday the [ __ ] I don't know what the
hell it's going to be just a European
one I don't know I got them all on my
phone there's a couple in July then
there's a one in August two in September
then like [ __ ] every Sunday in
October there's one then there's two
more in November and then that's it it's
pretty [ __ ] easy they're only a
couple hours you get to watch somebody
go like 20 miles an hour you get try to
look in the crowd
see all the people that go to the
Bilderberg meetings right and sacrifice
people and then you see a couple of bets
there's how much money is in [ __ ]
Formula One is when you look at like the
a-list movie stars and like [ __ ]
zillionaire
you know athletes they have a look on
their face like they can't even believe
that they're there feel like wow these
these people have money we thought we
had money and then we came here and then
we realized that we did we have money
but we don't have that kind of money you
know we don't back a [ __ ] yacht into
France these [ __ ] people back a yacht
into France and [ __ ] watch a race and
then continue on where did it go you
know you ever seen those people on
yachts every once in while you like
where to [ __ ] where they going do you
say like you cruise underneath of
[ __ ] you get your own Mountain it's
incredible you ever been on a boat just
by yourself whenever I'm on a boat by
myself I always have the same thought
there's no [ __ ] way I wouldn't do
something illegal if I owned a boat
there's no [ __ ] way the level of
freedom that you [ __ ] have the [ __ ]
you're on a boat going out of the
[ __ ] ocean all bets are up you get
out of the international waters I mean
it's [ __ ] whatever you say becomes
your law literally do whatever the [ __ ]
you want to do you're telling me right
now if you had a [ __ ] boat right your
boss was a dick right just [ __ ] ya
you know just sell out whatever they
promoted a woman right because they had
a [ __ ] check off a box they got you
are more qualified you came in every day
with your qualified swingin dick and
junk and they had enough of it
they told you to stand down and they
promoted this lady right you're telling
me if you got a boat right I don't know
you got the boat you didn't get promoted
but whatever this is my [ __ ] fantasy
trash trash and [ __ ] hypothetical
lady right I know this is could be
considered misogynistic this is the
woman I ran into the first 90 times I
tried to get something on
year I just feel it's like this that
would be the end of my dream but they
don't have any power uh it's a glass
ceiling well I'm running into their
shoes over here is they're banging their
head on the ceiling that was been my
experience anyway so let's get back to
the fantasy you're telling me if you got
a [ __ ] boat you know yeah I could
just I don't know just a kilo of cocaine
just for the [ __ ] of it just to have the
cash laying around your house you know
what I mean
get a kegger have some people over cook
up some steaks that's the way you do it
when you when you if you're [ __ ]
drugged is just every once in a while is
there a way to do that in the drug game
as the kids say
can you just every once in a while
deliver a kilo so no one picks up on it
all right you still drive your dented
Prius like meat Jesus my car needs a
[ __ ] bath like you read about I
literally walked out of a [ __ ] liquor
store today wasn't for me because I'm on
the wagon bloody mind got [ __ ]
married it's like but I'm I couldn't
make it because I was on the road so I
just got him some [ __ ] champagne [ __ ]
whatever and I forgot to get a card
before understand I'm giving it to him
I'll just say hey yeah that's got a card
he goes that don't worry you got the
booze that's what counts
sorry I bought a drink up hey Amy oh
yeah yeah look at my ass alright it went
the same boat oh yeah so anyways um I
came walking out of the liquor store and
I looked at my congas he's a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] but it isn't just on the
outside you know on the inside
everything's been taken care of right
I've maintained that thing meticulously
on the outside it's a mess on the inside
it's beautiful you know it's like an
ugly person just waiting for somebody
good-looking to come along and discover
that you know maybe they have something
to add to the conversation you know um I
don't want [ __ ] I'm talking about
so I'm just saying this is the way this
is if you're in just selling drugs this
is what you do if you can just do it
like the way Bush went to the [ __ ]
Army National Guard whatever [ __ ] he did
we just showed up everyone
while you know I mean played ping-pong
dressed like a sergeant then you just
went home for like [ __ ] six months
that's the way you deal drugs all right
you befriended drug-dealing you go
listen this is all I want to do I got a
boat okay
every [ __ ] once in a while you know
every whatever be [ __ ] 18 months you
call me up right
you got a key or something I throw it on
the [ __ ] boat I'll have it on ice you
know the coldest [ __ ] cocaine in the
universe and I'll [ __ ] delivered over
here right you break me up like [ __ ]
15 grand all right then you just take
the cash you just got it you got 15
grand in cash and you don't [ __ ] buy
yourself anything you know go out and
buy a [ __ ] flashy [ __ ] car or any
of that [ __ ] all you do you just have it
in the jar or some [ __ ] every once in a
while big games coming up you know UFC
event you [ __ ] order it that's what
you spend it on
you [ __ ] blow it on your friends you
know get some [ __ ] barbershop chairs
in the house just some stupid [ __ ] you
know nothing that cost that that's how
you blow your [ __ ] cash man you could
keep [ __ ] on the inside right you don't
drive around some flashy car with your
[ __ ] elevator shoes whatever whatever
whatever the kids do today I I don't I
don't pretend to know that's what I
would do you know and every once in a
while I don't I get in Jeep bank account
why would he do that if you got to pay
for the UFC event who gives a [ __ ] you
pay for it out of you ready a clean
money you know and then all the booze
money and all the other [ __ ] you
just take out of the jar there you go be
hilarious when you finally get caught
you know you just go to trial just Rick
look I just every once in a while it was
like every 18 months it's not even a
felony a year your honor and you know I
just I I didn't buy anything I don't
even watches the [ __ ] I just you know
like I got the NFL package I had my
friends oh everybody had their own
leather chair you ever watch those Elvis
documentaries well you know everyone was
going to go horseback riding and it
wasn't enough he bought everybody or
sandy got him a saddle and a little
pickup truck to put the saddle and I I
did that the judge back I was
you're dead dogs great well maybe you
can take that given nature and go to
jail and start giving some hand jobs
because the United States of America
buddy you know do you get a kilo of
cocaine right and then you [ __ ] take
your boat all the way out into
international waters right and then I
meet you on another boat and then I hand
you the key of cocaine and then you give
me the money in international waters and
we're both captains and what we say goes
and we say I say this is legal all in
favor there we go i III right can they
do anything I mean once it's the dude
who comes back in with the [ __ ] kilo
he's in trouble once you once you get
back within the borders you know I mean
can you sit there I'm really fascinated
with boats now can you [ __ ] study me
do drugs this is just fascinating thing
can you sit and just just on the other
side of international waters with a kilo
of cocaine out in the open just blowing
stripes is the Coast Guard's looking at
you just waiting for you to float
another 40 feet over and just be sitting
there going ah now I am the captain of
the ship in international waters and I
say this is legal
yeah probably can't do that right
because you know what they could do is
they could just come over and just say
that you were you were within the
borders of the US who's going to [ __ ]
know it's there where to get yours
you're out there in the ocean there's a
lot of questions I have about the ocean
this is one of the reasons why I don't
have a boat aside from the fact it's
just a [ __ ] money pit you know I mean
again of a boat you can have a friend
who has a boat that's the way to do it
right my brother always said you don't
want to vote bill you want you want a
friend AB a boat that's the deal
that's what it is then you show up you
know bring Google Tanqueray and tonic
you're a [ __ ] hero and then you guide
dogs the [ __ ] boat that's it he's
cleaning off the barnacles you know what
I mean he has to explain what happened
to the stewardess she was here a minute
ago I don't know we were drinking she
must have fallen overboard
right
that follows you around for us you
[ __ ] life um anyways so what do you
guys think I guess when you listen to
this it's Thursday so Game six in
Cleveland - night - night - night oh my
god can you imagine if they force a
[ __ ] Game seven that would be
something else you know what I mean who
knows then you go out - [ __ ] let's
I'm gonna give some Cleveland Cavalier
fans some advice here okay God willing
they forced a game seven okay because
we're all trying to avoid the dog days
of [ __ ] baseball you know I mean
nobody wants to watch that [ __ ] the
baseball players don't want to play the
games they don't the only reason why
they play is because if they didn't they
wouldn't make as much money but nobody
wants to [ __ ] play baseball from
mid-june - [ __ ] like the second week
of September any ballplayer if they
could fast-forward through all of those
[ __ ] games and just get to the
exciting part you know who's going to
win the division there's nothing better
than when it finally [ __ ] matters
after [ __ ] 263 regular season
whatever they play hundred eighty two
games whatever the hell it is 180 games
jesus [ __ ] christ you know everybody
in Chicago getting all excited about the
Cubs you don't I mean already rubbing
one out they're going to bust a nut and
[ __ ] the beginning July you got to
pace yourself you know watched any
pornos relax Cub fans put your shirts
back on alright how many [ __ ] times
if you fell for this not saying I'm
rooting against you but you know slow
your roll here Cubs fans these level
excitement they get you when you watch
them every [ __ ] year
it's literally like watching somebody
falling in love with this stripper you
know and you just sitting there like
what are you doing
you know you [ __ ] them you don't fall in
love with them right now I'm kidding the
part of being a sports fan is the
[ __ ] misery and you got a belief
that's what you got to do take the kick
to the seeds every [ __ ] year and then
maybe one time they actually win it then
you talk about that for the rest of your
life oh what a year
they still have the newspaper I framed
it
um and then your wife throws it out nah
maybe she doesn't maybe she's cool no
maybe she watches to sports too but then
she's probably fat yeah looks like you
guys start putting on each other jeans
in the morning just good leave mine yeah
but nothing felt weird yeah don't you
not usually the camel toe fit here I
guess these are yours this is got to be
the most [ __ ] bizarre podcast I've
ever done it's because I'm [ __ ]
exhausted mentally from doing this [ __ ]
I got halfway through this podcast I'm
not drinking and I was watching the John
Cooper story of Pistorius how do you say
his name the [ __ ] bass player there
what's in this documentary on him I read
the book on this guy too and like the
beginning is all great it's just once he
starts going off the rails you know so I
kind of paused it right at the right
part if you're watching the documentary
for the first hour and eight minutes
well actually probably but the hour
three minutes and then it starts to be
like yeah when they did this and did
that and this look at that governess
then it's a [ __ ] show so anyways the
[ __ ] was I talking about so I talking
about boats nose talk about the
Cavaliers now if he had some advice the
Cleveland Cavaliers okay God willing you
guys force a game six okay not for you
not for your city not to your fans for
me okay because I want another want two
more [ __ ] games tomorrow night and I
want another one okay before I slip into
the sporting abyss you know and I don't
give a [ __ ] that you only have to wait
another six weeks before you know
preseason football starts I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] about the draft
I don't give a [ __ ] about preseason I
don't give a [ __ ] about analysis I don't
give a [ __ ] the projections I don't give
a [ __ ] about any of it just let me know
when it counts I am so [ __ ] sick of
watching people stay
and up on a [ __ ] in front of a
goddamn screen trying to explain to me
what the [ __ ] I just saw what happened
and why it happened I don't give a [ __ ]
I get it you played the game and you
understand it on a level beyond me you
know I don't know just [ __ ] show who
won talk over the highlights and end the
[ __ ] thing you're going to sit around
and have goddamn debates you know what
do you think was happening tramps well I
think the problem with everybody knows I
don't know [ __ ] about basketball but I
can tell you right now if you [ __ ]
the Cavaliers as a [ __ ] comedian I
know what they're doing wrong at least I
think I do I would think if you up by 8
points against a team that can shoot the
[ __ ] lights out you'd want to throw
the ball around a little bit when it was
in your possession
rather than whoever gets the ball and
crosses [ __ ] midcourt just says I'll
shoot that night it doesn't even pass
the ball and you take like 2 seconds off
the clock probably not what you want to
do right see that I'm a comedian I can
figure that out do I need four people
and [ __ ] so well three people in
suits and you got to get a lady in there
right she's got a [ __ ] she's got to
run her Yap she's got to put her [ __ ]
two cents in right the only one the
worst [ __ ] things ever is is to be a
beautiful woman you know and you with a
really successful guy you know and you
just go around to parties and then you
just you just stand next to the guy
going is he going to introduce me is he
going to introduce me you get one size a
hi let me just stand there the other
night I did a gig and there was this
there was a scene afterwards and there
was all these [ __ ] you know rich
people with their beautiful wives and I
just I don't know I just started
watching the wives after a while I don't
know why don't they peel off and talk to
each other it's sort of a weird thing
where they just got to stand there
smiling you can see their face hurting
you know their feet hurt from the
[ __ ] pumps it's [ __ ] brutal you're
a beautiful woman what you should do you
got to marry like a [ __ ] six who just
can't believe that he's with you because
he'll let you go
and where some [ __ ] flatties some
moccasins he doesn't you have to jack it
up in the air and stand there smiling
next to him like one of those [ __ ]
psychos on The Price is Right waiting to
[ __ ] act like they're amazed about a
washer and a dryer got to stand next to
your [ __ ] guy he's wearing a sport
coat trying to cover up his [ __ ] man
tits and you got to sit there smiling
like you're happy you know put your
[ __ ] makeup on like some clown that's
about to be shot out of a [ __ ] cannon
you don't need that [ __ ]
what are you doing they got to start
well I tell you these [ __ ]
good-looking women that marry these
really successful guys and then just
stand next to them smiling you know for
the whole [ __ ] evening like a
stewardess at the end of a flight except
the [ __ ] it takes four hours for
everybody to get off the plane cuz I
thank you for flying high you know whose
fault that is it's their fault it's
their goddamn fault forget yourself into
that [ __ ] position some point in the
relationship you got to save listen a
mark sit down we got to talk guess what
[ __ ] Suzie ain't putting on the shoes
tonight all right deal with it not
standing next to you smile you want to
go to a [ __ ] brunch stand next to me
smiling with some aftershave on for
[ __ ] four hours I didn't think you
did
shut up I'm not finished some point you
got to have that conversation you know
I'm not trying to be mean here this is
supposed to be empowering I'm saying you
have the power to not just [ __ ] stand
there smilin like a god damn I don't
wait I don't know what it is you know I
don't talking about I don't know if I
saw that I watched an episode of house
of cards you know house of cards I last
like three I left it like three episodes
I just got sick of him [ __ ] turning
to me talking to me it's like dude will
you just live your life stop talking to
me that right there is the Secretary of
State he doesn't know then I'm [ __ ]
as well I shut up I get it I get it
stop talking what is this the Wonder
Years for adults oh god I'm in a grumpy
[ __ ] mood I love Kevin Spacey
why would I say these things why would I
say these things cuz I'm mentally
[ __ ] exhausted
I got another eight minutes so I got to
run my [ __ ] yep running my gap on the
Thursday afternoon podcast talk about
issues um what else I don't know that I
have anything else I still haven't
watched peaky blinders because I'm
trying not to drink and there's no way
to watch that show and not want to
[ __ ] start just pounding maybe I'll
wait till like the fourth of July
you know I'll just watch that's what
I'll do that's a good way to spend the
4th of July I'll ignore my wife and just
get blind drunk watching a show that she
can't understand you know I put on the
subtitles but she's just not into it she
just doesn't give a [ __ ] we actually had
this we had this argument the other
night right she goes when we go to bed
right she puts on the TV and shows as a
shows on what's [ __ ] hilarious to me
if she's always coming at me above my
temper and my yelling and flipping out
screaming at lamps and [ __ ] or yelling
at the TV or my computer
well me and my computer if you ever
heard the way I yell at my [ __ ]
computer you know like that couple that
just needs to [ __ ] break up you know
we got in my neighborhood dude I'm
telling you like [ __ ] two houses up
that they've been very good lately you
know but I'm telling you this like times
like you're literally like waiting to
hear the gunshot it's just [ __ ]
insane the way they scream at each other
it's the most unhealthy [ __ ]
relationship you know I've ever heard
and I got to be honest with you men you
know sometimes I hear it and I just I go
out of my porch and I just listen you
don't light up a cigar and just enjoy it
like it's a show now [ __ ] work yet
don't um but anyways so she's always
getting on me about my temper and [ __ ]
you know what's [ __ ] hilarious
it was every [ __ ] show she watches
it's just a bunch of people screaming
and yelling each other those reality
shows that are just wall-to-wall clams
that's all I mean you would think all
these feminists out there who are
sitting there trashing men up and down
all of bad stuff we do to them
admittedly you know what I mean we make
you stand next to us and smile for an
entire [ __ ] party
you know I'm sorry this is my wife oh
I'm sorry
this is the person that committed my
life - I'm sorry
did I ignore did I not even acknowledge
that you were [ __ ] here they deal
with that all [ __ ] night right
all that [ __ ] and we do that [ __ ]
but you would think that these [ __ ]
feminists right you think that David
they would have issues with these
[ __ ] reality shows because the way
they depict women is I don't give a [ __ ]
how many pairs of shoes how big the
[ __ ] house is how much jewels they
got hanging off of them they're still
going to [ __ ] - just [ __ ] bitching
each other up she was watching one of
these shows right and it was just like I
don't know 15 it seemed like there was
15 or 20 of them so you know there was
probably just three but that's the
amount of noise a [ __ ] woman can make
right three of them will sound like 15
it's like their defense mechanism
because generally speaking they can't
beat the [ __ ] out of men but if they
just start complaining it just sounds
like a platoon and you back down right
instead of giving all three of them on
one of those most slaps you know in all
three stooges would get slapped at once
anyways one of the episodes I saw like
you know like I said it sound like 15 so
realistically was for like six of them
right they went to like Rome or some
[ __ ] and I'm thinking I finally they got
these [ __ ] women out of this
cul-de-sac now they can now they can be
excited to be in Trump they go to
[ __ ] Rome they do the same goddamn
thing you know this [ __ ] come up to me
start talk about it's like you're in
Rome you dumb [ __ ] go look at something
go eat some food I know it's just a show
whatever she watches that [ __ ] I'm just
laying there I hate the [ __ ] show I'm
trying to go to sleep and I just really
she just watches he [ __ ] shows where
they scream and yell each other now
she's watching a [ __ ] show that's
about a show that's a show that's like
that to show about one of those reality
shows like The Bachelor you don't I mean
in Ana I don't what what the [ __ ] do I
know right 26 minutes let's read a
little bit advertising here why don't we
do that
alright type in the password you
wouldn't want anybody to break into your
computer bill with all your secret
all my [ __ ] slap-fight videos that I
watch why do I have a [ __ ] password
you know yeah I know this isn't going to
work either anytime I try to do the
pastor with one [ __ ] hand you know it
kills me to is I wanted to yeah of
course it didn't work I wanted a nice
simple alright here we go
Luke ray what the hell is this [ __ ]
alright here we go
lootcrate everybody ever been to
comic-con no wish you could take it home
with you God what an Aquaman suit no
Jesus bill just read the copy alright
have a little bit of it sent to your
home every month with loot crate packs
III and Comic Con happened just once a
year all this is some fun this is like
some mega nerd [ __ ] alright here we go
nerds perk up your ears this is like
when they after the Super Bowl when they
sell like the programs and the hats and
all that and look over to blue bag but
I'm going to save it's going to be worth
something right this is for the Nerds
here we go okay so evidently there's
something called packs evidently there's
something called III and I know about
Comic Con and they happen just once a
year each that's like the Grand Slam
like you know in golf you got the
Masters you got the British Open the US
Open and the PGA all right nerds have
the packs the III Comic Con and know
some Wonder Woman thing I don't know
usually that [ __ ] does it happen in a
town near you but with loot crate you
experience the fun every month get
exclusive products from top gaming and
entertainment franchise your your crate
will arrive between the 20th and 25th of
each month no commitment you're in
control
partner with top brands you get epic
exclusives in Star Wars Nintendo Marvel
and more Joon's theme explores ways
things can go wrong with dystopia
whatever that is it includes the
classics of Robocop Terminator
to Judgment Day and the matrix and new
faves by I'd said phase BioShock
Infinite and fallout 4 I've no idea what
initiatives you will get a figure cool
collectibles and of course the diss
stopper to stop errific monthly tea was
it mean an action figure go to loot
crate calm slash burn enter my code
birth deadline is the 19th at 9:00 p.m.
to subscribe and receive this month's
crate when the cutoff happens that's it
game over for less than $20 a month you
get 6 to 8 items that includes licensed
gear apparel collectibles and unique
one-of-a-kind items this is an over $45
value loot crate calm / / and enter my
code Barbie you are are to save $3 off
any new subscriptions I did a gig the
other night whether there was like
professional gamers there and stuff they
make all this [ __ ] money it's like
the greatest thing ever you played video
games for a living you know that's what
this country has become it's become like
you turn your hobby like me I turned
[ __ ] around telling jokes in a
warehouse into a career this guy plays
video games you know to me you like
rubbing one out you get into porn God
knows we don't manufacture anything and
there's like two things left in this
country growing weed and and [ __ ]
start like a non profit you know to me
most of those are [ __ ] anyways right
we got to help people we got to pinkies
there's a bunch but you know having two
pinkies affects most people a lot of
people don't even talk about it
you know all they do is just make it
sound like it's a bad thing and then you
also and you just give them the money
that's probably a bad example but you
know what I mean all right bowling
branch everybody bowling branch as you
set out to improve yourself there is one
simple thing you can do every day to
help you be your best in every situation
that's getting a good night's sleep a
[ __ ] mem I can tell you four days
sober I forgot what it's like to wake up
and be like you know what I want some
eggs whoa
bowling branch
the rest you need wrapped up in their
super comfortable luxury linens and they
do it right there the first bedding
company to be Fairtrade certified which
means your sheets come from the work
half work of happy hands and not from
sweatshops and beautiful package
packaging made entirely from recycled
and sustainable materials I wish more
companies did this all right you can
only get their sheets in one plate place
that's Boleyn branch calm well you know
you're paying for quality not department
store overhead you're getting thousand
dollar sheets for just a couple of
hundred bucks go to bowl that's Bo ll
and branch calm and they'll let you try
them out risk-free for 30 nights if you
don't like them send them back Ross you
have nothing to lose and it gets even
better go to Boleyn branch calm today
for twenty percent off your entire order
sheets towel blankets and duvet covers
everything plus free shipping and all
their products come beautifully packaged
in their signature boxes go to Bolan
branch calm today for 20% off your
entire order and use the promo code BER
Bolan branch comp promo code burr Bolan
branch compote a promo code burn all
right there you go what time is it
how much time did I do Oh 32 minutes oh
that was [ __ ] painless wonderful
alright hey everybody I'm heading back
these tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow
tomorrow I'm heading out and I got a I'm
playing in New Jersey at the New Jersey
PAC Center performance arts center
whatever the [ __ ] you call it then I'm
down in Atlantic City on Saturday and
then on Sunday uh playing some goddamn
place
alright all of the dates are available
on billboard calm guess what everybody
the the [ __ ] Belfast tickets are
already on sale I'm doing two shows out
there and I think Dublin guess who the
openers going to be uh when I say Joey
you say roses Joey yet Joe DeRosa Joe
DeRosa where the song
in something and there's something I'm
supposed to read some all think comedy
thing - where the [ __ ] is this thing
where is it hang on a second hang on a
second all things come here we go here
we go weekly tweet all right I do all
right you know what I'm not going to
tweet about this I'll talk about it
Yanis Papa's one of the funniest
[ __ ] coming up all those
characters and all the stand-up has a
new debut album called let me be honest
get it instead of let me be honest let
me be honest this Greek son of a [ __ ]
it's available today on all things
comedy records I got a tweet about this
I was supposed to do this five [ __ ]
days ago when an [ __ ] I'm going to
tweet about that right now all right
this has been the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday boarding
podcast and I just checked in on you be
a little music here and then we'll play
a half hour [ __ ] from a podcast a long
time ago maybe a little bit of time ago
but uh it's not going to be this one all
right it khunts have a great weekend
try to faster my god
[Music]
we are
now
the you
[Music]
they
you
you know
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr it's
the Monday morning podcast
what is it 148 149 there we go just
change West Coast time and I'm in a
great [ __ ] mood I'm not in the
goddamn Airport you know well I see you
know like you're going to [ __ ] talk
back to me
no I am in great mood I'm actually in my
apartment laying in my bed chilling the
[ __ ] out and I'm in a great mood
even though I had a head [ __ ] up week
really bill you had a [ __ ] up week why
is that well I'm going to tell you I've
been making jokes over the last four
months about me driving a dented hybrid
and talking about how emasculating that
is you know it's like already I'm
driving a hybrid so I had to deal with
everybody going do what are you a [ __ ]
you know what I mean suggesting that
because I'm making the air a little bit
cleaner that for some reason that on
some level that means I want to suck a
dick which is that's very childish yet
effective yet effective it's very hard
in a group situation while one maybe can
defend it but in a group situation when
somebody yells out what are you a fake
what ends up happening is they even guys
who want in the social circle will start
laughing and then it's like you know you
[ __ ] is people are laughing at the
question of what you would say like if
you suck dick or whatever you know for
you to start talking about you know how
you know how you're thinking about the
environment that actually digs the hole
deeper you know the people like well
maybe yeah look at them he's talking
about the environment only people who
are into the same sex are into the
environment they know it's funny
actually about the hybrid is when I
bought it a year ago I got a ton of [ __ ]
for it people made fun of the little
tires
and everything else you know but as gas
prices have crept up
I feel like 460 to 470 out here in Los
Angeles all of a sudden people are now
coming up to me being like so what show
let's deal with those cars but they uh
you know then they ask the usual dumb
questions like can they go up a hill now
no they can't
fortunately everywhere I want to go
involves driving on a perfectly level
surface if not a little bit downhill and
then after I take a long way around and
somehow I get back without having to go
back up the hill I just [ __ ] drove
down when gonna [ __ ] it sell a goddamn
car that doesn't go up a hill you know
ask me that question was my mother my
mom asked me that you got a hybrid can
it go up a hill now mom I moved to
Nebraska moved in Nebraska that's what I
did and it's funny there's no Hills in
Nebraska but there are tornadoes okay
okay so what happened 20 when driving
around this [ __ ] dented car oh if you
new to my page this is the Monday
morning podcast and I do want to be is
every single week you know people ask me
questions people send me information and
whatever and I babble about my life
while I hype upcoming gigs like the fact
that I'm going to be doing stand-up on
the guys Choice Awards this Sunday night
June 22nd on Spike TV guys Choice Awards
I believe it comes on somewhere between
8:00 at night and 4:00 in the morning no
I think it's 10 o'clock I don't know
when the [ __ ] it is but I was organized
I'd know that but I did six minutes to
stand up that day I believe I'm going to
whittle down to three minutes and I had
a great time and they were a bunch of
famous people there and I was jumping up
and down like a girl scout
in fact outside I was playing it cool
like hey there person who I've always
admired how are you yes nice to meet you
too and inside of like Michael
I can't believe I just shook their hand
and they said nice job you're funny it
was a thrill I had a great [ __ ] time
so I got that coming up Oh also this
week I'm going to be at the punchline in
Atlanta one of my favorite clubs see
what a great mood I'm in what's in last
week's podcast that was not a good mood
that was me in an airport wanting to get
the [ __ ] out of there oh and by the way
for those weekly listeners of my podcast
you know I was going from Raleigh trying
to get back to LA because it's [ __ ]
Raleigh there's no direct flight I had
to fly from Raleigh up to Cleveland and
then from Cleveland to [ __ ] in LA
well my connected my Raleigh took
Cleveland the flight was late because
wind if you remember and when I buy time
I got to Cleveland my flight to LA had
already left so I have spent five
[ __ ] hours in the goddamn Cleveland
[ __ ] Airport with with it what was
the big indie they give me a fifteen
dollar voucher to spend five hours in
that [ __ ] Airport and I was uh I did
my usual I flipped out a little bit I
was like fifty goes and the lady is like
well you know I actually hooked you up
they usually I gave you the dinner
voucher the lunchtime voucher is only
eight you know that's one of those times
you just want to reach across and just
grabs on by the throat even though they
didn't make the rule just to make you
feel better and be like [ __ ] you don't
give me [ __ ] eight dollars to sit in
this [ __ ] airport for eight hours all
right
I want I want one [ __ ] thirty bucks
and I want free internet that's what I
want okay I want some $50 voucher so I
can go get a chicken sandwich with
mushrooms oh [ __ ] was that good
god damn and I had a good chicken
sandwich in there it all worked out so
anyways this this is uh this is what
happened this week so anyway so I've
been driving around this uh
my my hybrid it was dented it got dented
initially because some douchebag backed
into me and I got that fixed immediately
and then the next time it got dented
because my girlfriend yeah I don't know
she misspoke in a parking way put it
that way and she [ __ ] I don't know
what
did but it came home and it looked like
[ __ ] Bigfoot had a pair of
timberlands on and stomped the goddamn
quarter panel so I've been driving
around with that right with scrape marks
on the side it just it just you know as
a man you don't want to have a car with
a dent in it it just makes you feel like
a [ __ ] loser forget about the fact
that it's a hybrid and it has those
little [ __ ] search roll up size tires
okay so I finally get the thing fixed
after four months you know because I
want to make sure she learned how to
parallel park you know before she [ __ ]
the thing up again so that's taken care
of so I get the goddamn thing fixed this
is how excited I am all right my girl
comes to pick me up at the airport as
I'm hugging her right like World War two
depended I'm looking over her shoulder
looking to see that there's no dent in
the car and that you know I mean it's
almost like I was cheating on her in
like an automotive kind of way so I was
excited the [ __ ] thing looked great
everything was fantastic and I drove
this car that was on Monday Thursday I
go over my management's office I've
aller the [ __ ] thing one of those
deals where you know I valet it but I
park it because there's a spot right
there
I go to my lunch I come back from lunch
and there's a [ __ ] dent in my car
again the exact same spot the exact same
side so now it's the bumper and I swear
to God I never understood the expression
I was beside myself I never knew what
the [ __ ] that meant but when in that
moment I get it it's some sort of
out-of-body experience well I was just I
had a look at my driver's license so my
license plate like seven times I was
like there's no [ __ ] way that's my
car this can't be my car and I didn't
just kept looking down and it was it was
my [ __ ] car so then I look over at
the valets okay mind you what's in the
exact same spot and they're not looking
at me this is all [ __ ] I put together
afterwards but I was so flustered
I came up there and I was like where's
the winner of in my god I [ __ ] voice
went up like nine Optus or even mad I
was literally like I thought I was gonna
fake let me see those old movies where
they got some blood and you know they
get those dresses down to the floor that
has like fifty two layers of underwear
underneath them that's why I should have
had all of those a [ __ ] hoop skirt
and I should have just fainted with one
of the little umbrellas that you spin
around and it doesn't really keep the
rain or the Sun off you it's just
supposed to make you look more
attractive
I should have been holding one of those
and that's what I should that's how
flustered I was so the [ __ ] parking
attendants are like I'm like well you
know whatever my car that was just like
uh all day somebody somebody hit hit it
somebody hit I might hit it I don't know
they Dave we backed it over there and
somebody hit it and [ __ ] did today you
know every [ __ ] word sounded like it
started with a date you know so I'm like
I can't [ __ ] believe it and then they
give me this sheet of paper to fill out
you know like that I should have told me
that they [ __ ] did it
because someone else hit me first of all
you saw the [ __ ] dent in his car
there's no way these guys didn't hear it
you know and they just automatically
give me this form saying that I guess
they're going to pay for it so I'm
filling the [ __ ] out and it wasn't until
I drove away that I started thinking
about it I pulled over and I'm looking
at the dent and it's the exact same
shape as the poles in the garage so
obviously one of those [ __ ] drove it
into a pole and then after they drove it
into a pole they stuck it back in the
space where I where I had left it and
then tried to [ __ ] didn't they were
looking down not making eye contact I
think they were trying to hope that I
didn't see it you know what I hope one
of those [ __ ] guys is one of my
listeners every week all right dude once
you just [ __ ] come clean let me know
you did it okay I know why cuz you know
I get fired right is that what it is
I just can't [ __ ] believe it man I
just is so goddamn depressing my [ __ ]
car he's got another goddamned I just
got to fix four days I drove around for
four days I don't understand it you know
what I mean it's not like when my car
didn't have a dent in it I started
driving around making fun of people who
had dents in their cars so there was
some sort of [ __ ] kamar going on well
I didn't deserve to not have a dented
[ __ ] car so so that's it now it's
unreal man I can't have a car doesn't
have a [ __ ] dent in it and I really
wish I didn't tell this story because I
started off in a great mood as you can
tell by my tone I'm not in such a great
mood anymore it's just really [ __ ]
frustrate I say what's extra frustrating
they give me this piece of paper with
some lady's name on it and they're like
yeah she doesn't call you in the next
five days give me a call and like I said
I was so beside myself I said okay and
it wasn't till day three I was like wait
a minute
somebody doesn't call me in the next
five days
come on the next five [ __ ] minutes
[ __ ] idiot you ruined my car or this
phantom lady ruined it and then you got
in it in it for some [ __ ] reason and
put it back in the same spot you 5 foot
2 inch [ __ ] jackass I just ah maybe
that's why I put it end it came and see
over the [ __ ] steering wheel alright
you know what I listened back to last
week's podcast I just really felt like I
sounded like I was too goddamn upset on
it and it was too depressing so I tried
to start this one off and try to stay
focused in a good mood and then look
what happened for them at 13 minutes in
and I'm already flipping out again I
just you know anybody else anybody else
got any [ __ ] stories out there like
that that can make me feel better
maybe I could read to some of the
listeners let me I want to hear some of
your I fixed my car or I just bought a
brand new car and then some [ __ ]
content and Jesus no not not drop at the
Seaboard all right let's get back to my
dates here okay so that's the deal I
have a dented hybrid again you know
let's think of some positive [ __ ] the
Celtics won one game like they had to
out in LA one of the greatest comebacks
ever and I get two more Boston let's
hope they're going to win it I actually
went to Game three Celtics lost that one
but I was still awesome to go to the go
to the finals but I got on it man of the
referees were they were little they were
crazy the amount of fouls that was the
game right after Phil Jackson was
complaining remember that game too when
they called 56 fouls on the Lakers and
like three on the Celtics so he bitched
about it and I think the referees got
pissed but kind of knew he was right so
they they were like calling a ton on the
Celtics but they also kind of go and
[ __ ] you Phil Jackson we're still
running [ __ ] so they still called a
bunch of the Lakers and I don't think
the ball went up and down the court
three times without them blowing a
whistle like there was never any sort of
like flow to the game and it kind of
sucked as a fan because they kept [ __ ]
blocking the excitement even when the
Lakers were going on a run you know even
as a self expand sitting there was put
you know I was cool to see them going
bananas and feeling like I was at a
finals but every time they start to go
nuts they call some ticky tack file and
then the other way when they would start
getting quiet and I start standing up
talking [ __ ] day a day they call another
[ __ ] one so and I know what the [ __ ]
they're doing but in that last night's
game I thought the officiating was
really weird it was like the beginning
the game like I they're going to let him
play they won't let them love each other
and then all of a sudden they stayed
start calling they just ticky tack it
it's not consistent this have been
consistent plus we lost so I'm probably
a little company too but anyways uh here
we go
punchline in Atlanta this week from June
19th through the 21st this is one of my
favorite gigs and I absolutely love
going to that club it's just an
old-school club if you live anywhere
near there
please come down I get a brand new hour
and I also have a solution to the big
ass problem I really do something that
would be infected a very effective if
did I say infective very effective
we're going to eat now within a aspected
like did you know what there's all those
things I never knew only difference be
affected I might have to look that up
alright and in July I'm going to be at
the improv in Pittsburgh from July 10th
through the 13th then the next gig I
have after that is July 31st through
August because [ __ ] said hang on hang
on the pages they're Zambia the comedy
works that's what it is economy works in
Denver Colorado from August
I mean July 31st or is it thirtieth
already turn the page let's [ __ ] day
in July through Saturday August 2nd nice
no Sunday it's gotta love that
yeah it's 31 days in July the 31 days
has November except for September and
Friday another one bill alright um do I
have anything else to hide I think
that's pretty much it
podcast questions all of a sudden
nobody's asked me podcast questions that
would happen last two weeks
I didn't answer any questions so now you
guys you can't ask me anything I get a
question for you where the [ __ ] are all
the questions are you over it I don't
know what okay I think it's time to wrap
this [ __ ] thing up what the hell was
I just looking up Oh effect effect I'm
try to teach you guys something affect
and effect you like how I don't know the
difference and I'm going to act like I'm
teaching you which of these sentences
are correct rising oil prices will have
an effect on nearly everyone that's
correct
with Annie right why you just give me
the [ __ ] definition I hear when they
do this her emotional outburst was
purely for effect you know at one moment
all these sentences correctly employee
affect and effect in most situations we
use effect as a noun and affect is a
verb well what the [ __ ] do they mean how
about giving me a definitions first you
know what this is like this is like how
they I was taught algebra
you don't mean like everything wouldn't
math up until eighth grade for me
anyways was numbers if you [ __ ] Asian
I'm sure you were doing calculus in the
third grade let's just stick with your
random [ __ ] stupid American here all
right right up to eighth grade it was
all [ __ ] numbers and all of a sudden
ninth grade comes around they throw the
[ __ ] alphabet in there and there was
no soda before they go in you know
little school speech like hey this is
going to be a little different
did you just started doing it he just
started throwing you know foil first
outside inside last you know salad all
that high school math oxygen angles are
congruent and none of it [ __ ] me and you
just you just repeated it like you're in
a cult they just stand up date opposite
angles are congruent
opposite angles are congruent did nobody
had any idea what the [ __ ] they was and
they just had a triangle on the board
that's what this website is like get it
right online calm there's no [ __ ]
definition
follow these player Webster's course mr.
theta second thanks sorry
is this exciting is this an exciting
podcast as I attempt to [ __ ] look up
goddamn word and fail miserably effect
eFax as you don't do this [ __ ] at work
that's submission you know you try to
look up like Robbie Knievel try to guess
what year he was born all right here we
go
perfect definition of effect to have an
influence or affect or a change in you
know what [ __ ] this word okay forget it
you know to me that's like the
difference between a truck and a car and
in the definition of car they describe
it as a [ __ ] truck you know what
sometimes you got to cut your losses and
you got to realize that you're not going
to know some things in life and that's
just one of them you know all right
what does this podcast this has just
been spammed for the last three minutes
I apologize you know what I just had to
eat you know what I should actually turn
this into a contest and say I'm going to
give up give you a free 100 DVDs if you
could guess what the [ __ ] I just ate
because you'll never guess what it was
picking the most okay I'm going to give
you hints and you can all play along at
home alright this is something it's a
dessert it's something that they used to
have creepy commercials about with a
high-pitched voice and you put it in a
freezer
three answer into one I actually just
had slice of cookie puss there's no way
to say that without [ __ ] laughing I
just had a piece of cooked plus ice
cream cake whatever the [ __ ] you call
it's ice cream and cake just like effect
and and effect they're the same thing
[ __ ] incestuous and yeah I got to
tell you something if you've never had
it it's just as disgusting as it sounds
you don't I mean some things are just
named perfectly and cookie puss it's
just what it is it's a stank ranked
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] disgusting cake like
if I was the right [ __ ] to pick just
gonna say if Paris Hilton was a cake she
wouldn't be she'd be like a [ __ ] blow
pop sorry uh I don't [ __ ] know all
right whatever my sugar levels up to the
[ __ ] roof why do I have up god damn
[ __ ] ice cream cake because I turned
40 last Tuesday
I'm Jim on Sunday that's the way I would
say I rejoined I'm like [ __ ] this turn
40 on Tuesday let me let me bang out 500
sit-ups the last 500 steps would be in
39 years old yeah yeah it's pretty
[ __ ] brutal up tastes and then
somebody shows up you know you have a
party at place and somebody shows up
with a cookie puss ice cream and you
know it's not that bad not because you
eat it it tastes good you're more
thinking like well you know maybe I was
addicted to sweets I'd be eating this
[ __ ] horse [ __ ] every day
all right did we learn anything this
week yes we did we're gonna learn the
fill bar it's going to be on the [ __ ]
thing that's why guys Choice Awards this
Sunday at somewhere between 8 and 4 a.m.
on Spike TV and I am to be at the
punchline in Atlanta and I don't know
the definition of effect and aspect and
cookie puss ice cream tastes like tastes
like
Eskimo uh yet you went down on a [ __ ]
Eskimo hooker
[Music]
it's really [ __ ] it's just it's
[ __ ] awful let me see if I can just
first of all Tom Carvel it's got a big
green [ __ ] ice cream nose with a
Conan and I just can't imagine like you
ever see those people that are so fat
they're like [ __ ] bedridden this is
the kind of [ __ ] that they eat because
you know everybody's out of shape I'm
[ __ ] out of shape right now you don't
I mean everybody once you get tests
there you got a [ __ ] gut nobody looks
feel without this shirt on so everybody
stop whining on that [ __ ] Biggest
Loser okay no one looks good
- quit your crying okay but those people
who get so big that they're just [ __ ]
bedridden you really have to go out of
your way you have to go above and
[ __ ] beyond to get that big you know
me baby syndrome you know the full
metabolism [ __ ] you and your [ __ ]
metabolism no you don't you are eating
cookie puss nightly nightly basis I just
had a snack what did you have I had
cookie puss all [ __ ] 3,000 [ __ ]
calories a slice family bill that's how
I like to [ __ ] end it is to attack
the bedridden that's it that's the
Monday morning podcast please up re up
with the questions I swear to god I'll
read them I will answer them next week
and somebody please give me a [ __ ]
definition the difference between affect
and effect because you know I died that
you know I looked it up and they use the
definition of the other word the [ __ ]
definition which is annoying all right
that is it
ah thanks everybody came up to see my
show in Raleigh North Carolina it's the
most disjointed [ __ ] podcast ever did
I use that word correctly um in Raleigh
North and out caroline's I'm adding a
bunch of new baits coming up I got a day
coming up with the stress factor in New
Jersey I got a college UMass Amherst I'm
going to be adding that date shortly
what else what else I don't know
sometime in August beginning
September so look for those dates and
anything else just go to billboard.com
and that's it all right
I'm tapping out I've got to get simply
kept the weaker exercise shoes
[Music]
too much tripping my souls wrong
please today name is why
[Music]
ah
long way
[Music]
Hey
where
along the way
[Music]
yeah
you
[Music]